support move University in the
production of more videos by visiting
the link in the description below where
you'll find more details thank you and
enjoy so Rutherford's gold foil
experiment with the hypothesis based on
the plum pudding model predicted that
the alpha particles should go straight
through the atoms of the gold foil but
in the actual result that led to what
this video is about the nuclear model
was there was reasoning that that there
was a tiny dense nucleus that contains
small positively charged particles that
he called protons which caused these
deflections so the nuclear model kind of
looks like this what is this green space
sent of shows the area where the
electrons can hang out and the center
here we've got the protons in the
nucleus of the atom right so this here
is the nucleus let me sort of label that
like this this portion here Steve
nucleus okay or those positively charged
protons are hanging out in there so that
already looks like a little bit of
problem we know that like charges repel
so that's got to be an issue but there
was another key issue with this model
and that was that it did not account for
the atoms entire mass so later in 1932
james chadwick discovered neutrons in
the nucleus neutrons were or are rather
neutrally charged particles that when
added to this model accounted for the
atoms entire mask as well as as impacts
why the nucleus can even exist with
protons hanging out inside of it because
these positively charged particles would
likely repelled but neutrons being there
kind of helps with that if you will
anyway I hope that video was helpful in
kind of visualizing how they came up
with this nuclear model based on the
gold foil experiment thank you for
watching you found that video helpful be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
content also follow move University on
the different social media links in the
description below thank you and happy
studying